thomas vous êtes donc sur place les
autorités craignent des débordements à
l'annoncé des résultats
on est face au scénario qui était
redouté par les autorités celui où les
résultats sont contestés où aucun des
deux candidats est en mesure de
revendiquer une victoire nette et sans
appel la situation risque donc de
s'éterniser des accusations sont d'ores
et déjà échangés entre les deux
candidats la crainte maintenant c'est
que ces invectives se concrétise sur le
terrain entre des militants pro trump et
pro by donne quelques manifestations
sont d'ores et déjà prévues ce mercredi
mais il semblerait que le pays soit
suspendu à l'issue de ce scrutin
particulièrement indécis et même
l'annoncent d'un vainqueur dans les
prochaines heures ne devrait pas mettre
un terme aux débats bien au contraire
quand les résultats sont serrés dans
certains états et aussi parce qu'il ya
des accusations de d'irrégularités qui
plane sur le décompte les barricades ne
seront pas prêts d'être retirée ici à
new york tout comme dans les autres
villes des états unis les autorités sont
sur le qui-vive beaucoup de police
locale avait anticipé en suspendant
toute demande de congé de la part de
leur effectif pour pouvoir mobiliser le
plus de policiers possible si la
situation le nécessite évidemment les
regards sont tournées maintenant vers
washington et vers la maison blanche qui
est véritablement barricadé depuis
plusieurs jours hier soir déjà quelques
dizaines dans thiva étaient présents à
proximité de l'édifice présidentiel et
l'autre crainte c'est la confrontation
armée entre les franges les plus
radicales des supporters de trump et de
baden baden et une ville cristallise
particulièrement ces craintes et la
ville de portland dans l'orégon le fbi a
indiqué suivre la situation de très près
dans cette ville qui a été secouée ces
derniers mois par des manifestations
parfois violentes
un mot enfin pour souligner cette
tension régnant ici aux etats unis si le
fait qu une célèbre chaîne de
supermarchés a retiré il ya quelques
jours de ses rayons
les munitions et les armes qu'on pouvait
auparavant et trouvez merci beaucoup
thomas pour tous ces précisions